So I will not be talking about a VTK degrader.
So I'm going to be talking about goldcadamide in the role of, which is a cell mod in combination
with rituximab in patients with relapse, refractory, diffuse-sorged basal lymphoma.
So as we know, in the current era, approximately two-thirds of patients with newly diagnosed
diffuse-sorged basal lymphoma will be able to achieve cure with chemoimmunotherapy.
Unfortunately, that means that approximately 30% to 40% of patients will experience relapse
or refractory disease.
While effective treatment options are becoming more widely available, some of these are still
limited by access to them or patient fitness.
So there's still an area of unmet need for these patients with refractory disease.
Goldcadamide is an investigational potential forced-in-class oral small molecule cell mod
agent, which we've heard about earlier in this meeting, which is designed for the treatment
of lymphoma.
So goldcadamide's role in the treatment of relapse, refractory, diffuse-sorged basal
lymphoma was studied in a Phase I-II study.
This study was done in 2009-2002, which we have some recent data updates presented at
ASH by Hoffman et al., which I'm going to go over.
So we've heard of the cell mod mechanism of action from some of the earlier multiple myeloma
talks.
You know, it shares a similar mechanism to mizictamide, so I'm not going to go over too
much of the details, but a similar mechanism of action is that it binds to cereblon and
causes it to favor the closed active conformation.
Which leads to increased IKROS and IOLOS degradation via the proteasome pathway.
Where it differs from some of the multiple myeloma cell mods is that it does have a preferential
viability in the lymphoid organs, which makes it an attractive option for its use in lymphoma.
So CC99282 was a Phase I-II multicenter study using goldcadamide as its monotherapy and
later in combination with rituximab in patients with relapse, refractory, non-hostile disease.
You can see here the study schema, Part A being the dose escalation, where they were
able to select the schedule and the dose.
I'm going to be mostly focusing on the updated data from Cohort C, which is highlighted there
in the green box, which included both dose of 0.2 and 0.4 milligrams of goldcadamide in
combination with rituximab.
And you can see the primary objectives and secondary objectives report on the right.
So for in this cohort that included the two different doses, you can see some of the different
characteristics.
You can see some of the patient characteristics here.
So generally, this was a pretty heavily pre-treated population with a median prior lines of therapy
of 4 to 5, with some patients, as you can see, they're receiving even up to 11 prior
lines of therapy.
These also included or like over half of patients received some form of T-cell redirecting therapy,
whether that was a Bispecific or CAR-T, and approximately a quarter in both
of these arms had received some prior lenalidomide therapy.
Also of note.
You can catch on the bottom part of the box there that there were some patients that had
primary refractory disease with the last line of therapy.
So you can kind of imagine that these were pretty difficult to or patients with pretty
aggressive disease.
Here is the latest patient disposition update from Cohort C.
So a total of 77 patients were enrolled.
It appears a bit discouraging in the sense that 65% of the patients ultimately came off
the study, with six patients being able to achieve a durable response and six patients
being able to complete the plan.
Two years.
I'm going to go over some of the complete and overall response data, which shows why
it still potentially has promise.
Going over the treatment adverse events, as we know, hematologic toxicity is a known side
effect from cell mods.
In particular, with glucatamide, there seemed to be a dose-dependent toxicity with the
higher doses resulting in an increased risk of severe neutropenia, approximately 80%,
as well as an increased risk of febrile neutropenia.
Notably because this shares some mechanisms with IMiDS, there was an interest in seeing
how many VTEs, or sorry, thrombotic events were present.
And they did not seem to be very common.
Thrombobolic prophylaxis was not required in the study.
So a total of three patients did have a VTE.
For some of the later phase three studies I'll touch upon in my conclusion, they do
require VTE prophylaxis just because of the increased risk.
So, you know, with regards to the overall response and complete response, you can see
here that in this pretty heavily pre-treated population, on the left includes the overall
response by dose level, and you can see that the higher dose level was associated with
a much higher overall response rate.
With the green subsection of the bar showing that some patients achieved a complete response
in approximately 46% of cases, they also did a subgroup analysis in patients with previous
T-cell-directed therapy, and those patients also showed a favorable response with 32% achieving
a complete response.
Here is a dissection of how different patients did on the study.
And the patients highlighted on the top in green are the ones that were able to achieve
a complete response.
And you can see that for the patients that did achieve a complete response with Jusqualcatamine-Rituximab,
the response generally was durable.
And unfortunately, there were some other patients that came off study due to progression of
disease, infection, patient death, or investigator discretion.
But for the patients that are able to achieve a response, they do have durable benefit.
So in conclusion, Jusqualcatamine-Rituximab demonstrates promising efficacy in heavily
pre-treated patients with relapsed refractory diffuse short-spaced lymphoma.
For the patients that are able to achieve a durable response, this does provide some
additional benefit.
And it's rational for investigating its role in other settings, including the front-line
setting.
So this data supports the ongoing development of jusqualcatamine-Rituximab for patients in
non-Hodgkin's lymphoma, including in the Phase III GOAL-SEQ-1 study, which I'm participating
in my institution, as well as the Phase III GOAL-SEQ-4 study in second-line follicular
lymphoma.
There are some other ongoing studies in which they're investigating its use prior to CAR-T
as a bridging therapy, which I don't include here.
But that's probably also another role that we'll see in the future.
And so for that, I'll conclude my presentation.
I'm open to questions or any discussion section.
Thank you.